c'est vrai que ça ça a été un truc
énorme qui s'est passé donc pendant la
cérémonie miss france ait eu des
répercussions terribles et ce soir on a
envie d'avoir la vie des protagonistes
alors vous n'avez jamais parlé 1 depuis
le début juste jurer qu'on revoie la
vidéo d' excuses de sylvie tellier avant
de vous écouter c'est parti on vient ce
spectacle de samedi c'était un très
grand cru de miss france et des costumes
magnifiques avec un petit couac quand
même mais bon un gros couac en coulisses
et d'ailleurs je voulais m'excuser
auprès de la production très les
candidates dont cette intimité a été
dévoilé ça aurait pas dû se passer c'est
une grosse erreur de notre part et ça un
petit peu gâchée sochaux qui a été suivi
par plus d'un million de personnes
alors voilà donc qui a vu cet incident
en direct alors je voudrais dire merci à
manon jean mistral miss corse vous avez
18 ans merci d'être avec nous car la
bonne et sow miss aquitaine zae 20 ans
merci d'être là également il ya m jeanne
élise mouillac avocate au barreau de
bordeaux
merci d'être là et maître catherine la
forêt avocate au barreau de dax et vous
défendez ces deux jeunes filles alors
c'est vrai que ça tourne dans la partie
de cette séquence vous aujourd'hui on
ait eu un mois après environ voilà
pourquoi vous avez choisi de parler
aujourd'hui et qu'est-ce que vous avez
l'intention de faire est-ce que ça a eu
des répercussions dans votre vie
quotidienne on va on va demander à manon
alors en fait c'est grâce à vous que
l'on peut s'exprimer
on a eu enfin moi pour ma part j'ai été
contacté par des magazines mais c'est
seulement sur le point j'aurais dit que
ce qu'on allait faire et pouvoir
s'exprimer en tant que personne et pas
une femme voilà ça s'est passé derrière
voilà en fait notre famille ça atteint
notre famille nous notre futur aussi
parce que ça prend des proportions
énormes
on s'est retrouvés sur un site porno
enfin des choses qu'on a pas demandé
maintenant quand on tape votre nom au
plus sur google ou tombent directement
là dessus c'est ça qui vous dira oui
c'est sûr les réserves je sais ça on
nous assimile directement à ce cet
événement quoi c'est vraiment voilà vous
êtes devenus les deux jeunes filles de
qui on a découvert la poitrine nommez
moi je parle franchement c'est vrai
aujourd'hui vous de tête j'allais sur
sur un moteur de recherche vous tapez
les noms ou de banos ou deux car là vous
tombez directement là dessus alors que
mine de rien vous aimeriez être connue
pour autre chose quoi mais en fait on
pensait faire un concours d'élégance et
en fait maintenant on se retrouve dans
une position où quand on parle de nous
c'est forcément de la vidéo on pense pas
miss aquitaine et miss corse elles ont
fait un beau show est long bien défiler
elles ont bien parlé
on nous assimile vraiment à cette vidéo
et ça en fait ça détruit notre image et
ça nous a détruits de nous à l'intérieur
vraiment vous êtes vous êtes blessé
depuis cette affaire parce que vous
pensez
je savais que ça n'a pas été fait
sciemment wind en asie par tf1 voilà moi
je défends la prose je défends tf1 et
j'ai des fourmis dans la société endemol
je pense pas qu'ils aient fait ça si
amants ils n'ont pas voulu vous faire du
mal
mine de rien moi j'ai des doutes parce
qu'on vous voyez vraiment c'était fin
août la direction de tf1 que la
direction d'endémol ils ont aucun
intérêt à faire ça se dire on va essayer
de de se faire du buzz là dessus ils ont
rien à faire dans les coulisses voilà
ils ont aucun intérêt à faire ça mais en
attendant il n'y a pas eu d'excusé
derrière enfin le petit a eu de petits
actes par exemple endemol m'a envoyé des
fleurs et du chocolat
oui voilà mais il n'y a pas eu de
de mode excuses ils se sont ils nous ont
pas enfin moi pour ma part on m'a pas
appelé d'accord s'excuser ce que je
pensais enfin jeu pour moi c'était
important de m'appeler pour me dire
voilà vous jeûnez et on est désolé que
ça se passait comme ça mais d'accord
donc ça c'est voilà donc c'est juste ça
que j'aurais voulu qui se passe et ça
c'est pas fait donc on peut c'est que ça
va avant qu'on écoute les avocates qui
soit est ce que vous comprenez ces
jeunes filles mais moi franchement mais
ça m'a vachement ému votre histoire
parce que bon alors déjà vous êtes corse
vous avez 18 ans il ya eu millions de
personnes qui ont dit vos seins on nous
a salis on a sali votre image alors
qu'ils aient fait exprès ou pas pour moi
c'est scandaleux et je trouve ça mais
pour moi c'est inhumain qui vous est
même pas appelé pour s'excuser
je ne peux pas comprendre qu'est ce qui
se passe dans la tête nous sommes
plongés sylvie tellier qui vous a envoyé
juste un bouquet fermé alors nous on a
on n'a pas repassé la séquence là on
peut pas on va pas là l'an passé voilà
parce que bon voila c est ça y est c'est
énoncer voilà ce qui s'est passé mais
c'est vrai que moi je ne pense pas
qu'ils aient fait exprès ça arrive dans
la tourmente des enjeux la petite erreur
c'est d'avoir voulu remettre des caméras
en coulisses et c'est vrai que c'était
un petit peu le risque la neuveville
verde quand vous dites je ne pense pas
qu'ils aient fait exprès tout est là ils
ont buté sur même moi mais je suis sûre
même qu'ils n'ont pas fait exprès mais
j'ai une bisontine exprès de montrer
demande à l'est derrière les saints de
ces deux jeunes demoiselles mais ils ont
fait exprès de mettre une caméra là
c'était pas la première fois mais quand
vous mettez une caméra là vous vous
exposez à ce risque donc le risque était
prémédité
le risque était là et on savait très
bien que quand on met dans les loges au
moment là où elle se déshabille une
caméra forcément un moment vous allez
avoir une image qui va arriver quand
vous choisissez de la diffuser c'est que
vous passez du risque a la certitude
alors septembre au cac était réalisateur
qui est un garçon chambre oui je pense
et un amour de mec il travaille avec nos
prix et voilà de cette année nous avons
voulu être dans les coulisses du show
pour être au plus près de la préparation
des candidates pendant les répétitions
nous avions positionné un cadreur dans
les loges tout s'était bien passé donc
nous avions conservé le dispositif pour
le direct e
c'est un agent de vente du direct on a
on a la chance d'avoir eu une
missionnant c'est une ex miss qui est
toujours mise pour moi c'est delphine
des films est ce que si il vous est
arrivé la même chose
est ce que vous auriez été choquée est
ce que vous auriez été blessé mais je
les comprends et je comprends que vous
soyez blessés que clairement sa
ternissent sa ternissent votre histoire
miss france et c'est vraiment dommage
parce que c'est censé être quelques
debout dans une vie pardon en revanche
vous le savez pour que tu désolé parce
que là alain rochât un gros chat en
revanche vous le savez pour faire de
plus en plus d'audience il faut apporter
de la nouveauté
les fans de miss france sont très
friands d'être plus proche des
candidates
on a envie de savoir qu'est ce qui se
passe vers ce show derrière ses rideaux
comment les filles se prennent toujours
là donc il y avait un cadreur en soit
c'est une très bonne idée
en revanche la gagne 33 nana qui se
prépare pour un show donc c'est possible
il y en a une qui passe voilà onze ans
elle enlève son soutif parce qu'il a le
truc maillot ou a fait une grave erreur
mais c'est pas fixe et un risque de voir
plus clair en couple alors les deux
avocates sont là merci à m jeunes et les
mounaques alors et maîtres catherine la
forêt qu'est ce que vous voulez
aujourd'hui pour vos clients
alors il faut plutôt amer c'est un votre
discours c'est qu'est ce que nos
clientes attente d'examen
alors qu'est-ce qui alors aujourd'hui il
est certain que cette situation est
intolérable
vous allez porter plainte alors nous on
aurait aimé un échange éventuellement
avec endemol ce qui n'a pas été bonne
avec tf1 les deux les ballons avec
endemol jeu peut-être faire quelque
chose avec tf1 pour l'instant ce
week-end non non non ils vont pouvoir
discuter avec vous il faut ils sont
ouverts à la discussion mine de rien
mais on espère parce que pour l'instant
il n'y a pas eu d un échange pourquoi il
ya un préjudice qui est énorme pour ces
jeunes filles parce que leur vie privée
a été dévoilée on les voit désormais sur
un site pornographique mais y'a aucun
aucun tf1 n'a rien fait pour l'accord
limiter la diffusion de ces images
pour proposer quelque chose à ces jeunes
filles c'est pour ça qu'on est là
aujourd'hui pour les soutenir et
éventuellement à l'issue de cette
émission effectivement mettre en oeuvre
une procédure entre tf1 et endemol
absolument alors moi je vous dis je vous
dis tout moi je me fais le voilà le
message émane de ce qui se dit sur les
réseaux sociaux
il ya des gens qui lisent sur les
réseaux sociaux tiens est ce qu'elles
n'ont pas trouvé un moyen de faire le
buzz de faire parler d'elle derrière ça
et voilà mine de rien le fait d'intenter
une action en justice envers tf1 ou
envers endemol
est-ce que ça à faire reparler d'elle et
ça va plus est les maîtres mots là sur
la bière elles ont signé un contrat il
participait à un concours des lots
d'élégance avec vraiment des missions et
des obligations spécifiques
est ce qu'il est normal aujourd'hui
qu'on les voit partiellement n'est
dénudées surtout réseaux sociaux sur des
vidéos ça leur situation aujourd'hui
elle est inadmissible elle ne répond en
rien aux obligations réciproques qui
résulte du contrats qu'elles ont signés
avec avec miss france d'accord qu'à ceux
des médecins manon est ce qu'aujourd'hui
cette cet épisode malheureux a changé
votre vie et est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
le dire mais non je pourrai plus jamais
me présenter un concours de beauté
franchement je pense que je peux faire
ce que je veux tant que je suis maître à
vous mon image malheureusement elle
s'est dévoilée comme enfin comme je
n'espérais pas en tout cas j'ai pas
signé pour que ça se diffuse comme ça et
pour encore moins pour comprendre les
images de moins dénudés quand vous
disiez le buzz c'est pas moi qui l'ait
voulu et il est tombé sur moi comme ça
surfer sur le buzz
je vous pose les questions qui voit là
oui normal on a déjà vous la poser oui
enfin c'est pas du tout une question de
base qui allait de moins à l'aise ical
en fait on ne veut pas faire le buzz
on veut juste montrer qu' on n'est pas
des objets ce n'est pas soit belle et
tais-toi miss france on est des femmes
et on veut se défendre quoi pour ça on
veut montrer aux femmes que voilà que on
est des êtres humains qu'on a une
conscience vous avez été blessé et qu'on
accuse
blessé sur vos parents bas vous avez 18
ans et 20 ans comporte un manque de
respect juste voilà la question que j'ai
envie de vous poser quand vous dites on
va se tourner vers tf1 et endemol
qu'est ce que vous voulez vous les un
dédommagement aux voix la préparation du
président est une réparation pécuniaire
vous voulez une réparation si vous
voulez quoi
une association visiblement eux mais de
quoi vous voulez quoi elle va pas
rentrer dans le détail là dessus mais de
toute manière techniquement oui
peut-être mais techniquement
lorsqu'il ya des conditions de base pour
le concours miss france
on ne doit pas montrer une épaule on
doit pas marre montré certaines parties
de son corps et à partir du moment où en
plein milieu de l'émission elles sont
filmées dénuder pour elle le concours
s'arrête d'un point de vue strictement
réglementaires dont il ya véritablement
posée d'emblée en forme abel d'emblée
elle ne pouvait plus continuer miss
france c'est vrai que ça alors c'est un
désastre
ça veut dire que l'élection est
invalidée voilà c'est ça mais toujours
prédictions pour la balade hors miss
tahiti
oui ben merde alors il contestait la
russie a regardé miss france mais je te
supporter de ce à quoi franchement on
mesure en fait j'ai lu kant a dit que
des gens sur le net qui dit cameron
poste dont tu as beau faire quoi doivent
se taire non mais c'est sûr non mais
vraiment nous avions à l'époque se terre
doivent gérer c'est dans leur contrat
match espagne c'est normal qu'ils
veulent demander des réparations
j'aimerais que les chaussées d'accord je
te dois croire qu'elles viennent de dire
ce que vous venez de ce que vient de
dire m mouillac joly c'est que c'est
vrai que là ça soulève un truc c'est que
peut-être que le concours issue à être
invalidés parce que vous avez raison si
on voit s'il ya des règles strictes et
que vous avez on a dévoilé des parties
de votre corps qui ne devait pas être
dévoilés c'est vrai que là là ça peut
être compliqué terex a peut être qu'à
une multitude de miss qui ont été
destitués de leurs types parce qu'elles
ont fait des photos topless ou des
photos partiellement dénudé et et l
aucune mesure n'a été prise au moins
pour s'excuser vis-à-vis de ce qui s'est
passé également nous sommes saisis
nous avons été saisis deux jours après
l'élection et nous intervenons seulement
aujourd'hui d'accord si elle souhaitait
leur but initial était d'obtenir qu'une
réparation
ça ferait longtemps qu on aurait engagé
une action votre but c'est quoi c'est
quoi votre but nous c'est ça que je veux
savoir c'est quoi vous dites on veut des
anneaux mais c'est en fait c'est même
pas et vous qu'est ce que vous voulez
bon on a longé magie des excuses des
excuses des excuses
oui on vous a vu tf1 alors qu'est ce
qu'ils m'ont dit que tout de suite
carole la productrice a présenté ses
excuses et que terry vous a aussi
présenté ses excuses je alors oui autre
plus loin et autres prêts il y avait un
différé est ce que là vous allez
attaquer sur le différé pascal un
différé de deux à quatre minutes
justement dit moi il ya des séquences
qui ont été coupées pourquoi cette
séquence n'a pas été couplé l'actrice
est bien entendu seul problème c'est que
c'est pas vraiment en direct mais ce
proche de dieu voilà de deux minutes
donc il ya une multitude de caméras
pourquoi au maintien ces images on voit
au départ qu'il y a le visage une d'une
sharon qui prend tout tout l'écran au
lieu de changer d'image il ne change pas
d'image parce qu'elle fait on voit
qu'elle s'interpose entre la vidéo et
manon notamment et elle dégage sa tête
et là on a l'impression même que l'on
zoome sur la camerata fois on n'a pas
supprimé ces images d'accord alors donc
vous voulez juste des extérieurs des
études et vous les ont données vous vous
vous donc ce qu'est ce que vous voulez
de plus en fait moi je veux pas dès ce
mois je fais des excuses je les
dédommagements à vouloir dédommagement à
montrer je veux montrer aux à la france
qu'on n'est pas des objets belle et tais
toi je ne montre pas mais c'est un à la
france entière celle hors de question et
que ça serve d'exemple pour les autres
et que ça se reproduise plus pour la cci
mais c'est parce que c'est un manque de
respect pour les miss futur et pour
celles passées aussi si le contrat a été
violée là ça veut dire qu'ils auraient
pu être violée n'importe quand alors
manon et paraît que vous avez arrêté
l'école depuis
oui mais c'est pour ça rien à voir avec
ça non pas vraiment mais juste quand les
gens vous reconnaissent ils vous parlent
que de ça oui on m'assimile directement
à vous dévoiler et vous partez de
travail de variétés travail à cause de
ça à cause de mon nom à la c'est grave
ah ouais oui j'ai des valeurs on sait
que ça dès l'hymne de ça mais j'ai le
fait d'aller bosser j'arrive pas à aller
vers les gens directement avoir
communiqué g dimanche est toujours à ça
oui voilà c'est très dur pour moi d'un
accord viable parce que des fois je ne
faut pas mélanger par contre parce que
miss france on a passé une très belle
aventure
ils ont ils ont été très protecteur sa
exemple payer un voyage de rêve ça tout
c'est bien très bien passé avec la promo
c'est juste ça qui a fait que maintenant
on associe la ministre en sont associés
à cette vidéo est très dur pour nous ce
qui nous énerve tout le monde nous en
parle les gens qu'on ne connaisse pas
moi quand je suis rentrée à lille dans
l'avion quelqu'un m'est venue
l'interpeller dans l'avion et ont envahi
la crise en tout le monde ah c'est vous
qu'on a vue à poil réagira si vous
partez sur alors on va on jouerait pas
légion on va on va voir des jours le
premier soin je le jure venir du doubs
sur premiers sondages avant de voir le
deuxième sur l'évasion fiscale de dany
boon justesse que vous êtes choqués
chocat 42% pas choquer avec cinq ans du
moment donc c'est à peu près kif kif
bourricot et sur les miss sur la fère et
les miss le scandale des deux miss au
sein dévoilé
c'est alors le zonage est en cours en
tout cas voilà on va essayer de voir on
va essayer de suivre cette affaire voilà
j louis ii puisque c'est vrai que une
invalidation n'est pas exclue d'après ce
que vous dites est est ce que si
invalidation vous pouvez demander que le
concours soit refait avec vos clientes
par exemple parce que l'on souhaite je
pense pas aux journaux du tout ne vaut
une véritable père de chance sur le sur
le concours de sciences et à les
représenter
non jamais non jamais vous êtes aux
vacanciers on peut pas en être vaccinés
mais on l'a fait de façon il en a le
droit
on a fait notre aventure de l'autre côté
après en laisse on est à notre place est
vraiment on a profité comme il fallait
alors d'accord rien à reprocher à que
très vite - à votre avis ce qui me
choque toujours c'est l'image qu'on veut
donner de qui on est vraiment dans la
vie sylvie tellier par exemple qui fait
des belles excuses à tf1 il est sympa
non elle n'est pas sympa j'aime ça
c'est regarder les halles pour ça non
mais c'est pas bien ce coup lire ce
qu'il dit en coulisse et qui n'est même
pas passé un coup de téléphone c'est ça
ce qu'elle devrait faire avant d'être
devant laquelle voir la belle pardon oui
moi je n'ai pas eu d soit la tabelle
étaient les fautes
moi j'ai pas eu à défendre c'est
l'éditeur fournit suivi de l'hymne et
vous vous avez envie moi j'ai eu tf1 et
sylvie un bon voilà je n'ai pas différer
mais chocolat d'accord vous avez un
téléphone
est-ce que c'est faux en tout cas merci
d'avoir réagi à tout ça